Meet fashion model Han Hyun-min.
He's young, gifted and black,...
...but in South Korea, that can be something.
Sixteen-year-old Han is half Nigerian, half Korean...
...and is the first mixed-race model in South Korea.
Growing up, Han was pointed out and talked about.
Some mothers even told their children not to play with him.
His agent overcame concerns putting Han on his books would be a huge gamble...
...and he now regularly appears in glossy magazines...
...and has walked more than 30 shows of Seoul Fashion Weeks.
Han's still stared at, but now it's more for his model good looks than the color of his skin...
...and he hopes his career will serve as an inspiration for the next generation...
...of multiracial children in South Korea.